what's up guys my name is CH welcome
back to my code review series a series
in which I take a look at all the stuff
you guys send me now we're continuing on
with this 2000 hour 2D game Mansion I've
already made two videos on this topic
last one will be linked up there for
some reason you guys were a little
annoyed at me for not looking at the
actual code and whilst yes it is true
that in the first episode we just looked
at the GitHub read me and then in the
second episode we just looked at the
main like first C++ file in the project
you can't rush these things there's just
so much to say in every fragment of this
project that pillow that pillow is
sideways that I've kind of been enjoying
just taking this slow but if you if you
want me to speed up then fine in this
video I'm going to try just to fly
through all the code so that we actually
cuz quantity is better than quality
right we'll just fly through the code
and we'll we'll try and get an actual
proper look at this engine and read some
of the code that we have here okay so
without further Ado here is the one file
that we looked at let's take a look at
what actually happens there's the UI
project selected which I mentioned you
don't want to have in the runtime so it
doesn't quite make sense that it's here
I think I saw some people commenting
saying that it's you know there's
another project oh there there's another
solution file here and this second
solution is this this like asset
solution and that I think includes the
engine yeah here we go then it's got a
main function and all of that so this is
in fact like a separate Solution that's
supposed to be your game I still don't
like that system I still think that it's
better to have it separated into
different modules there's honestly a
heap of reasons why but without getting
too deep into this I think my main issue
with it has to do more with the build
configuration like because this project
is physically a different project to
what we had before so the setup that
we're seeing here are basically these
two there's the engine and then there's
the the engine also but in the form of a
game but this is part of the assets
project and this is part of this right
engine project that means that all of
these specific you know like
pre-processor definitions include paths
all of that is going to be duplicated
across these two projects whereas if you
just have like even build systems aside
if we were just using a project that was
called Sprite engine and then we had a
project called editor which used it and
then also a project called game which
used it then we could obviously just
maintain that Central project file and
if you had a build system you would
maintain that module as just like a
static library with all of its own
configuration and all of that stuff it
would just be a lot easier to organize
not to mention the fact that since this
is the editor but it's also the engine
it's a little hard to tell what's what
you know like which files here are
editor only like there's this in UI
inspector that has nothing to do with
this so is it included here oh it's not
there's no GUI components but then
there's all these engine components and
half of them are here half of them I
guess AR are not I mean this is here but
this is here inside a filter and I guess
like this is the this is the same
physical file on dis right you see what
I mean like this just becomes harder to
organize so I would definitely bring all
of this common engine core engine
functionality into a separate module
Visual Studio project static Library
whatever you want to call it called you
know Sprite engine core or something and
then have all the other projects
reference that now speaking of which I
know that I do a lot of talking about
what I would change and not so much
showing exactly how I would do it so
what I am planning to do for the next
video hopefully in this series is
actually put what I'm saying into
practice and show how I would organize
this and how I would set it up and will
actually do that to this project I think
that will be a little bit more helpful
let me know in the comments if you think
that's a good idea if you are just
getting started with programming and you
also want to learn math and there's an
excellent free way that you can do that
with the sponsor of this video
brilliant.org brilliant.org is an
amazing website filled with lots and
lots of really high quality courses on
various stem topics as I mentioned
fantastic place to get started with
computer science there visual
interactive engaging courses will really
help you learn a lot about the basics
and think like a programmer then this
also extends to math no matter what your
math level is if it's really really
beginner and you have no idea what
you're doing this everyday math course
is fantastic for that it'll teach you
the ropes it'll really help you out but
then all the way to things like linear
algebra and calculus again being taught
in this visual interactive way with
these widgets you can play with getting
quizzed so that you learn and retain the
information that is brilliant.org in an
artshell but hey don't take my word for
it you can get started for free
brilliant has a 30-day free trial that
you can use to look at everything they
have to offer and then if you do go on
to like it then the first 200 of you who
sign up for an annual membership will
get 20% off huge thank you to
brilliant.org as always for sponsoring
this video one final thing that's
bucking me a little bit about this as
well is the fact that it's not just in
some kind of reasonable location this
asset like it's called assets and it's
inside the resources and template
because I guess the this is like the new
game template so that's kind of
interesting because like I mean as as if
I need more reasons to not like this not
being a separate project but one other
reason is what happens when you add a
file to the engine like if I'm
developing the engine and I add an extra
file like a C++ file how is it going to
get compiled as part of this project I'm
going to have to manually add it to this
project file because then it just simply
won't get built as part of this solution
and as part of this project so yeah
whilst whilst I can see why you may have
set it up this way there are there are
just better ways to do that and as I
mentioned I'm going to show you exactly
how next video now I think before we we
go on maybe we should just try and run
this actual game engine because I'm
pretty sure so it doesn't build and
release I think from last time but it
does it does run and we can try and
create a project and then I didn't like
this I remember I didn't like this being
in the C drive okay so I've just made
this code review directory and then I
think create is this form so I have to
click this Plus and then I get to give
it a name so let's just call this
example project create okay it's run a
bunch of stuff over here 256 files
copied so yeah everything from that
template has been copied and then now I
have this example project which I can
click on and it will open over here it's
opening on my other monitor by the way
just cuz I've made that monitor in my
main for the purpose of this video but
here we go so here we're finally looking
at this project we're finally looking at
this Sprite engine project um it's also
a little bit blurry you can see the text
here I mean assuming it won't help but
the text here is blurry that's because
yeah it's fine on this monitor although
it looks very like not anti-alias and it
doesn't actually draw properly on this
monitor if I just switch my recording to
the second monitor then you can see how
like the the panels I guess don't get
resized properly it's a bit weird anyway
I suspect the blurry text is probably
because I've put my display scale to
150% again for the purposes of recording
this video so it's a bit easier for you
guys to see if you're watching on mobile
I don't know if I'm going to like try
and make a game with this or something
thing this is all very like I can't
resize any of the panels This
inspector's all I I think it's really
not playing well with my display scaling
which is a shame then we got these like
scripts here what do I do with this okay
create Sprite okay so here we got a
Sprite we're getting somewhere um what
does that button do oh oh These are like
gizmos I see and and right click is to
move around scroll Wheels to zoom in so
I have gizmos I guess that I can use to
resize
this but I have to grab the top bar okay
this is I mean this is very bizarre I
got this we're going to show and hide it
again I can't see half the
inspector which is bizarre um also okay
that's just moving the viewport I guess
I thought it was moving the Sprite
Sprite R okay we got the default PNG
here that we're yep sorting layers we
got box collider so got it's got some
Physics I guess using box 2D probably
definitely not the biggest fan of this
UI in general it needs a bit more I
don't know color or something edit the
Box collider like see all of this like
you know even something as simple as
making this green or maybe not green in
this case red or blue or I don't know
something so that it's not cuz what's
the Gizmo what's the Box collider like
it really does need some some UI work by
the way if you think I'm being mean then
refer to the original email in which the
author asked me to roast them as much as
I can so honestly I don't think I'm
being mean you have no idea what I'm
capable of I guess we need like a camera
right so I mean I can only create
Sprites what's oh okay so there's just a
single camera and then it's got zoom and
speed I don't know if this is supposed
to play but I can't press that I was
hoping it would like fall cuz I I made
it a box collider right let's see Sol do
it does it also oh it needs a physics
probably needs a physics body as well
and scrolling down is a bit broken I
don't know if this is just I don't know
I'm not sure I think this UI in general
is broken cuz it was weird on my other
monitor as well but I can't there's a
physic body so if I hit play I'm not
seeing anything unfortunately I was
hoping it would like fall or something
and then there's these scripts like what
am I meant to do with this I should
probably watch the video you know what
maybe I won't try use this today I'll
I'll watch the video that was in the
GitHub read me to be honest I don't know
how deep I want to go into this project
but maybe I'll I'll watch the video and
I'll try using it next time cuz this is
just I don't know I'm seem to be failing
at oh okay so that lets me move the
position and that this is the scaling
and that what then play Just does
nothing apparently let's save this and I
can build it oh maybe I have to build it
and then run it okay whatever let's go
back to the code okay so I've collapsed
everything so we can start looking at
this uh we'll just go into the main game
engine file cuz I'm assuming that
contains all of this and we can start
looking at the codes so that has okay so
immediately like I say this all the time
but honestly I like it when private is
below public and my reasoning for that
is always the fact that when you look at
a class you immediately want to see what
it offers you and this is what it offers
you because this is like the
implementation details of this class so
that's why I always put this below
especially if you've got so much stuff
it's kind of like when I first open this
I have to scroll past all of this stuff
to see okay this is how I use the class
externally because usually with classes
you're using them more often than you
are developing them and if you are
developing them having private beard
anyway I don't know why I'm talking
about this so much let's move on so
here's a instructor okay I noticed
you're using this a lot and then you're
also using the mcore convention but not
always so I'm guessing you're not here
cuz these are public and then these are
private so they have mcore I like mcore
I think it's great is mcore mixed with
snake case which I don't think I've ever
seen before but whatever uh you have
this everywhere you definitely don't
need that the only time I would ever use
this when referencing an object or a
symbol that is part of this class is if
there's a name conflict so if you have I
don't know a parameter here like M close
or something then obviously there's like
to differentiate between these two you
have to use this because they have the
same identical name usually that's not
an issue if you use mcore and for those
of you wondering about public variables
in my naming convention I like to
capitalize public variable names like
this so the first letter is is capital
that's just my convention so if I had
like a struct filled with data members
they would all be Capital without mcore
mcore only for private members okay so
then um let's see here so we're using
sfml we're creating a render
window this definitely like when it
comes to abstraction in my view this is
not abstracted enough because you're
creating windows and like different
Windows to render to and all these event
types like that should be a little bit
further away I would probably package
that up into a window class just to
abstract all of that away and also you
could build up your own API around it
because if you look at this like there's
a lot of stuff here that is specifically
related to window things so poll events
is obviously about the window so is
update window style there's this render
window window events all of these things
could be abstracted further down into a
window class and that would really free
up free up this to be more about all the
different systems of the of the engine
cuz this is like this is game engine.
CVP so this is equivalent to Hazel's
application. CVP this is like the main
Hub of where everything gets kicked off
from and where everything is kind of
stored some things are stored statically
or might have different lifetimes and
you know things related to a project
that you have open will be stored
relative to that project because their
lifetime so for example an asset manager
is going to be relevant to a project
because if you switch projects you're
obviously going to unload the asset
manager so it makes sense to tie the
lifetimes together you wouldn't have it
for the lifetime of the whole
application but in general that
application should really be like this
this Hub where you have your app and
then everything else all the different
game Engine Systems they all connect
here whether it be like renderer sound
physics storage you know whatever else
you have there window like that all
connects here and this class should be
the glue that ties all of this together
and also controls these systems as well
as kicks off the rest of what you
actually have in your app so whilst you
might have different systems like Global
Systems tied into here here you'd also
have app basically running update you
know render whatever else you have maybe
have a layer system and you have to go
through all the layers and execute
update so that you actually do something
in your application that would kick that
off so therefore as you do add more
systems it makes sense to separate them
out into their own files into their own
classes so that this is a lot cleaner
sfml in it happens over here and we have
some kind of cleanup initializer so we
have in a class called initial init
other classes wow that name uh and again
with functions like you really don't
need that you really don't need this
everywhere so in it scenes scene names
okay this is interesting scene file
scene file path to scene file and it's
it's just a it's just a Define oh my
gosh what's going on here file data
macros Doh really wonder what that file
is okay so we have these various
extensions this is okay path to
resources you just have these strings
being joined to like concatenated here
yeah this this I really don't like um
and then I'm just not sure why and then
you okay so you have I'm guessing let's
go back to that I'm just lost for words
here let's go back to this do I still
have that open assets yeah I do okay so
this is the assets thing so
maybe when you start okay but you just
call game start I'm just wondering where
does where do the scenes come from
because if I'm just launching this I'm
guessing the scenes are so this's
current scene in the the SC names and
these are
private so where do they come from I
mean it's private so it have to be here
unless we have friend classes which we
don't so let's try and track this down
like scene names I don't understand
where they come from we do init scenes
so they've got to come from disk so we
have a file called scenes. scn okay sure
and then that file we're going to open
that file up and then we're going to
read it and then we're going to figure
out if that the so that's going to be a
list of files to load basically so we
have a file that contains a list of
files to load they're all going to get
pushed back into this
scenes uh
vector and then I'm guessing we'll have
a way to open a particular scene and
this is all inside initializer CPP and
then there's this like user this is all
static so this is all static and then
there's user first scene name which has
to be defined here to be scene one H I
would definitely do this differently I
would have I think that you should have
the concept of a project file so the
project file if we just look at Hazel
for a second so we have Hazel ships with
this sandbox project and we have
sandbox. hpro and that is a file this is
a file that we use for development so
this isn't shipped but this is like a a
file that you can load and you can see
it has a start scene now the reason this
is only used for development is first of
all it's just a bunch of text but also
you know the start scene being a file
path that would get converted into an
asset handle and we would have the scene
file be part of the asset pack and it
wouldn't like the file path wouldn't
exist of course it would just be
referenced by its universally unique ID
anyway the point is though you can see
that the the concept here is that you
have a project and all the metadata
related to that project even if it is
just for development because this does
extend to the runtime just in a
different form format is all of this
being stored centrally so that you know
for example what is the first scene that
I start when I run this game now there
is also not a collection of scenes it's
really odd to me that there is a
collection of scenes inside a
file and one of them is hardcoded to be
and and of course I I'm assuming you can
change this so this is the other problem
that that I'm not really liking like
file data macros like this is where
exactly
this is inside engine Source data so
here it is file data macros you can
customize this per game I'm assuming so
like you could have well proof app
sandbox is the name there so you could
have like you could override this and be
like all right for my game that's the
start scene but then that means that
this entire code base is relevant to a
specific game but I guess that's the
case anyway because you're compiling it
all into one project anyway so obviously
these exact C++ files that referenced
here it's almost like you need a
separate checkout for game then every
time you want to make a game you should
even though you have this uh launcher
where you can load any project you want
if you just use this one instance of
this game engine then any changes that
are made would automatically affect all
the games which also isn't a great
system because well if I want to for
example do this then that would make
sense if I was making more than one game
but anyway going back to this scene
system which is crazy having a scenes
file which lists out like all of the
scenes that are part part of this
project oh hang on I think I'm
misreading this a bit so if sin size
greater than zero we do this otherwise
we okay right so if we read that file
and there's nothing in there then we use
the first scene name which would be you
know scene one which is a separate file
so that that's if we don't have an
actual scenes file or if there's nothing
in it if it's like empty or whatever
because if if it does manage to load
scenes from the file it will just be the
first one in the list okay so that's
already a little bit better than a
hardcoded name but still having a list
of scenes like that and then we just
automatically load the first one is
really interesting because my next
question would be how do you transition
between scenes would you really just be
like all right now switch to scenes 2
when we switch to something else rather
than either having a handle or a file
path or a name or something relevant to
that scene because then what you'd be
creating is let's just say scene zero is
your main menu so you're inside your
main menu and then you need to move on
to your main game scene which then would
kind of be hardcoded as the second scene
within your list of scenes and then
maybe that's level one so really if you
want to load level five cuz that's where
you're up to in the game you'd load like
this or I guess I guess it really would
be five then cuz Zero's main menu like
you load that and again that has to be
in a particular order inside a text file
so yeah I really don't like that that
aside from that uh custom file formats
I'm also not the biggest fan of I would
much prefer to use something like yaml
which is you know a wellestablished
format with a syntax and with a standard
not to mention that when you have to
encode more complicated things it's a
lot easier because it's standardized
it's kind of done for you and then
finally as I mentioned a lot in the last
video you have to keep coming back to
the main user base of this which is the
players playing the game so when you
ship this what happens to this because
obviously there's no distinction here
between what is part of the development
or part of the editor and then also part
of the runtime so as far as I'm aware
this happens in the runtime as well so
you have to load a text file filled with
all these different scenes like if if
someone just wants to play a particular
scene if someone's stuck on level five
and they want to advance you could just
edit this file really easily and just
change what scenes are played and in
fact if you rearrange them as well and
they're just addressed by index that
could also be a problem but it's not
even like the rearranging is I'm not
even worried about people hacking the
game or just going in there and changing
stuff as much as I am like trying to
organize development because you add a
scene in the you can't add a scene in
the middle of this list because it
pushes all the other scenes down which
could be problematic yeah it's just a
really weird it's just a really
interesting way of handling scenes that
I don't think I've ever seen before ha
pun intended all right anyway let's get
past this in scenes thing so then we
load whatever scene was selected whether
that be a scene called scene one if
there's nothing in the list of scenes or
the first list in the list of scenes so
now we're trying to load it and how do
we load it SC scene gets set to scene
name wasn't SC scene already scene name
yeah because we're trying to load a
scene what okay so you're just resetting
it just in case I guess this gets called
from somewhere else maybe current scene
a scene name clear engine up before
scene load which is Sprite repository
clean up which oh delete
at oh my gosh what is h what is this so
this is a list of Sprites inside Sprite
repository we need to iterate through
every Sprite pointer there and then call
a function inside Sprite repository to
delete at I because it might have
children oh my goodness me and where are
the children stored so we have to go
through that H parent poter Charles okay
all right I see what's happening here oh
this is I don't like this either so when
you store things so what's happening
here is inside the Sprite repository we
have a list of Sprites right and it's a
vector of Sprite pointers but these are
not all of the Sprites in the scene no
no no these are all the parents these
are all of the root level Sprites in the
scene so what you have is a vector which
stores Sprite pointers continuously in
memory like this however each of these
guys has the potential to have children
but the children aren't in this main
Vector they're stored as pointers within
each Sprite so then you essentially
inside each one of these you have a list
and this can keep going forever and that
is not good what you should absolutely
do is this should be every single Sprite
in your scene you should just have a
flat list of every Sprite in the scene
and the way you have children is you
don't have Sprite pointers you just have
indices so in other words this is a
vector right so we have indices for each
of these elements this might be 14 15 16
you could just have Sprite at index one
what children does it have oh it's got
14 15 and 16 how do I get those I look
at the main list of Sprites and I pull
out this why because again it's this
concept of keeping your memory
contiguous meaning when it comes time to
render everything you're not walking a
tree and going through all of this
trying to get through all the Sprites
you're just iterating over a vector
really simple really nice and easy when
you need to delete all the Sprites like
we've just found here you just iterate
through the vector and you delete
everything there is no oh does this have
children okay if so let me go down a
level to see the vector of children they
have I need delete all of those but
first before I delete all of those I
need to look at their children to see
what's up like you can see this is just
a nightmare this is very confusing and
this is actually much more complicated
than just simply doing this another
potential video idea by the way might be
how to set something like this up
instead of doing this because I can see
why this would be potentially the first
thought but it's just much better to
have a flat list and that's it and again
the way that I come to that conclusion
usually like when I'm trying to decide
okay what is truly better is the use
case right it's the what am I doing most
of the time and most of the time I am
going through everything in a kind of
linear like fashion and I'm trying to
render it or update it and if it comes
down to me having to go to all the
children and navigate that's that's a
problem now the thing is every child
here here will also have a parent index
though right so for example 14 15 16
like we've written here they're going to
have their own children potentially sure
which again would just be a a vector of
integers right which would be the
indices but then you'd also have a
parent so their parent would be one
right so each of these would have a
parent 14 15 16 cuz they're up here and
the parent will be one the reason why
that's useful is because if you are
using this parent child hierarchy
because you need to calculate the world
transforms so if every Sprite obviously
down the hierarchy will have a local
transform that will be relative to its
parent then of course you need to go
through and you need to calculate the
actual World transform before you can
render any of this and when you do that
you can see whether or not you need to
because there's a parent or not so in
other words one would just not have a
parent which could be expressed as
negative -1 could be you know you in 32
Max or whatever you want assuming zero
is an actual valid index and so in
certain situations you would potentially
need to see whether or not you have a
parent or if you're like a root level no
so what I'm saying is this functionality
of yeah but I want my root level nodes
you could still have that obviously like
it's just a matter of checking to see if
this has a parent or not and same with
the the childless like the the leaves
right if you have a leaf that has no
children then you could easily just
check to see whether or not there's
anything here or is this Vector empty
because there are no children and I
don't know if this feels like a minor
point but this is this is a major point
because this is the this is the heart of
the entire engine the entire Sprite
engine this Sprite repository like this
is your this is the heart this is
probably the single most important
system in the whole engine because
everything revolves around well these
things these Sprites these entities so
getting this right is super super
important and again something as simple
as just cleaning up would just it would
just be this like instead of delete at I
it would literally just be that like you
just go through and delete that and in
fact if these Sprites were shared
pointers or whatever in the first place
then it would be even easier you would
just do this that's it like how how
great is that how easy is that writing
complicated things like game engines
actually comes down to simplifying as
much as you can because the the existing
natural complexity of what you're
working on that will organically grow to
just massive Heights and so I think
being a good experienced programmer a
lot of the times really is about trying
to keep everything as simple as possible
because believe me if you blow out
things like this then you're just not
going to be able to scale like you will
not be able to scale well and still keep
all of the moving Parts working because
that's another thing about a game engine
it's just it's a whole bunch of
completely independent systems that have
to come together and synergize well if
they don't fit together and work well
with each other nothing's going to work
that's one of my favorite things about
working on a game engine the fact that I
can it's like anything I can think of
would probably fit in somehow into a
game engine any kind of system I'm
interested in physics I can take a look
at that I'm interested like fluid
simulation yeah sure path tracing like
yeah yeah Chuck that into the
application you know what I mean like
there's it's just built from all of
these completely different systems and
keeping everything sane keeping yourself
saying but then also keeping the code
saying is such such an important skill
and it definitely does take time to
develop but definitely try and always
ask yourself am I doing things as simply
and as clearly as possible or am I
adding complexity that probably doesn't
need to be there all right we touched
the code today I fulfilled my promise
hope you guys enjoyed this code review
if you did please don't forget to hit
the like button I really want to
continue looking at this I think there's
so many different actionable outcomes
that we're finding here things that we
would definitely want to do to improve
this next time as I mentioned I want to
take a look and show you how to organize
this project structure just into
something better and also how to convert
this to actually user build system I
think that'll be really helpful
hopefully for the author of this project
as well as for everyone else watching
who might have something similar let me
know what your thoughts were about
everything that I mentioned here in this
code review don't forget to check out
brilliant.org Theo and I will see you
next time goodbye